now then freak out our next guest is a
household name i'm
sure you're going to recognize nyle
rogers is an award-winning guitarist
singer-songwriter producer and founder
of course of the band chic
he's worked with the likes of david
bowie madonna and diana ross and so many
more and now
you can apparently enjoy the company of
the multiple grammy-winning superstar
from the luxury of your own home he's
inviting fans to join him for a covered
safe
personal audience through the world's
first voice
interactive digital portrait the legend
himself
joins me now to tell us more
well you're there somewhere there you
are sorry you didn't pop up there no
rogers we're not worthy
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on sky news tonight now i want
to dive in
on this project it is the forever
projects in the room
with neil rogers available available at
hereintheroom.com and it builds it as
saying it's the
next best thing to meeting you in
the flesh so i take it it's not your
average zoom call
tell us about it um yeah no it's not
your average zoom call
in fact you are talking to me and the ai
is so brilliant that it um i
answer you in real time and as i get
smarter
i l i love talking about me like sort of
in the third person
nile gets smarter the answers become
even more
uh precise and is anything
off limits can people ask you anything
they like and
you will deal with it there is
nothing off limits as a matter of fact
uh when i
was uh trying it out for the first time
myself
uh i can't help it it's a little kid in
me i said uh what's your name
and it said my name is not rising wait a
minute my name is now what day were you
born
he gave me his birthday and i said
that's my birthday you're trying to
steal my identity
and and we actually had um
a a real personal conversation uh
or i had a real personal conversation
with myself
it was quite funny and do you play any
music as well
um i actually only play a wee bit of
weir family
and i don't play it um as vigorously
as i would if i were really playing the
song i just
sort of map out the chord changes and uh
and i use that as an intro to take my
position to wait for
the questions now reading the blurb it
also says we can ask you
about uh things like how was it to work
with david bowie and uh given i
spots uh the thin white duke uh
behind you over your right shoulder i
think with though
one of his platinum discs i suspect um
tell us then what was it like
to work with david bowie i was amazing
as a matter of fact you know what i'm
gonna
i'm gonna correct myself i do in fact
think i play
music because i think tell the story of
let's dance
and i always like to demonstrate it
because just talking about it if you're
not a musician
you don't necessarily understand but
when i can demonstrate it
it becomes really a lot clearer so i may
in fact
do it with that song and because they
asked me
um a humongous amount of questions
i can't even remember everything that
they
they could have easily asked me the
chord changes to
i don't know of get lucky or something
and maybe i played that
well just what i asked you about david
bowie there jog the memory
now can i ask you though you know what
has it been like for you let's
let's get a bit more serious for a
moment too you know during this awful
pandemic we've been through and i
understand you you lost your mother
during the
the course of the pandemic and that was
that was very difficult in terms of
saying goodbye and our condolences for
that i mean it's it's
it's been such a difficult time for so
many hundreds of millions of people
yeah that was um i've still not quite
gotten over that and she died uh two
days after christmas
um it's it's been very very difficult
but
you know having something like this
project
uh has given me other things to focus on
and because i'm such a workaholic
that's actually helped me it you know
just
concentrating trying to make this uh
project worked as perfectly as possible
being very sincere being very honest
being very open
and and that was the thing that was very
very very very important to me because
everybody has seen my life i i wrote my
autobiography uh there's no way i'm
gonna
uh uh uh be revisionistic
uh i'm you know i'm gonna tell you the
truth so it's fun
it's fun to learn the truth and hear the
stories and most people probably haven't
read my book so you
you get the real stories of what
happened
and what about the effect of the
lockdowns on so many people
in your industry no money coming in not
able to perform
uh some pretty terrible stories out
there
it's it's horrible and uh in the u.s
now it's really just gotten
[Music]
really out of control and i i don't
understand
why uh the masses
aren't really listening it's it's
getting
um a little crazy um and and also of
course
economically it's just uh
a disaster you know i think uh
uh president biden is uh really trying
to help and i think
from what i've felt from the people
around me people
seem to be a little bit more optimistic
but it's going to take quite some time
to resolve this issue
because you know every day they keep
talking about new variants and this and
that and
um yeah i just have my fingers crossed
that uh
we'll get it under control as quickly as
possible i've had both my vaccinations
some time ago
so i actually uh even though i'm still
incredibly cautious i do walk through
the world
a little bit more um
i don't know i'm not nearly as nervous
as i once was
and now i really can't ask you anything
can't i i understand that
many many moons ago when you were a
teenager you were actually in the
in the black panthers and i've just
watched that wonderful film i'm sure
you've seen it jesus and the
and the black messiah and i want to ask
you this
sin since then um i mean do you feel
that anything really has changed
in the united states in terms of its
attitude to race
um some things have changed some things
have
felt like they were a move forward other
things have felt like they were moved
backwards
almost a slingshot reaction to
some of the progressive things that have
happened
um but i'm i'm hoping that
through all the chaos comes order
because i'm an optimistic person
at heart and you know i just think that
things have to get better because it's
pretty it's pretty bad now
yeah okay now rogers really great
talking to you as i say really can't ask
you anything and
we can continue that uh with the forever
project
available here hereintheroom.com thank
you very much indeed for joining us
on sky news tonight yeah please check it
out you'll have a blast
it's fun i'm joining in